what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to a clip from the
whatever podcast but before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell and like
the video on your way in let's get
started
um okay that's been my mother starting
from nothing to something she's from
below minimum wage to above minimum wage
and by herself she did that all by
herself so would she have been better
off if she had a guy yes of course but
you know in those time periods when she
needed the guy the most she really so
she needed a guy she needed a guy but
you don't obviously my mom was So Into
You know a relationship where it's you
you put a certain degree and you put a
certain degree and you make a house what
are we talking like like in a marriage
that's what I always think I'm like what
is she even saying no seriously okay
come on you know that if you have two
options life with the husband been life
without a husband you would pick a
husband
so why do we live in this delusion like
I don't need a man when we really do
need men to survive guys think about it
if your car breaks down you're going to
a guy most likely if the power goes off
a guy has to come fix it like just
because we can function in society like
just because men have built a society we
can function in and they allow us to
survive without them it doesn't mean
that we don't need men because we
literally need men to do everything you
need two people are you still talking
about 50 50. I want to bring Justice
you don't you don't mind Brainerd you
don't mind wash her you don't force it
or agree anything she chooses to agree
to go what is she into if you lay down
now that Foundation a woman came into a
woman cannot look up to a man who is her
equal
but okay you said you're in favor of 50
50. Justin your thoughts on 50 50
dynamic I don't believe in 50 50 Dynamic
I believe a man should take care of a
woman in every way and I think that's
what he gets to do and of course
A real man you will accept that because
you'd be happy to be in his frame
because you look up to him you want to
get behind him you want to be on that
ride he's going to take you on exactly
yeah I also have a certain point yes but
I'm gonna but I'll tell you a man's not
a man is not going to sit there and
listen to you tell you tell him your
standards because
I'm going to lay out a foundation of
what I wanted to reset guys donated 200
Jerry will never really cares about this
woe is me backstory you came from a
broken home and you dunked your dignity
in the dumpster because you decided to
not get professional help for your
mental issues
[Laughter]
mental issues are kind of shaky I have
trust issues yes of course I do but then
again you can't you can't reach hold on
just a second two hundred dollars I'm
not gay but I'd go gay for water
[Laughter]
engage the cups through my soul like a
chocolate blade blade ever since I
discovered Wallace I got off Viagra
welcome to the whatever podcast
I'm glad to be here thanks Mike I think
uh
that's crazy hey man we're gonna go to a
Burger King afterwards Mike just for you
bro can you tell me where the nearest
Burger King is 24 hours he owns 300 of
them
no that was Mike Davis yeah I think it
was Mike Davis wasn't it that was Mike
Davis Mike continuing you're in Miami
right yeah Mike Davis do you own any
Burger Kings in Miami what could he host
you at the Burger King like sure bro I
mean maybe after what he said maybe yeah
it might be it might be tough um sorry
we got two uh tts's that came through
one right after the other you guys were
kind of having an exchange Justin did
you want to come back in or did you
I'm good no no problem at all I said I
said what I had to say I I do believe
that a man is going to want to take
charge and control the relationships and
oftentimes I think that women
particularly ones like you that are
going to be a bit more headstrong
they're going to want to hold on to
their independence until they find a man
that they find is worth Letting Go
what's really hard for a woman nowadays
is to find a man worth the [__] enough
for you to be able to let go and I think
that'll be one of your biggest
challenges moving forward particularly
because how headstrong you are you know
and and that's all I really have to say
about it if you find that right guy and
he comes through and he's just like you
just everything that you think you want
is is no offense not true when that man
walks into your life and you're going to
know you're going to be able to put a
lot of walls down that you wouldn't
previously be able to put down because
the man is worth you being able to do it
and when you trust you can be inside his
frame and you're safe inside of that you
will let go no I so that's
don't have a hard time finding a guy
because of how headstrong she is so she
well she's critical of men too yeah
in her particularly she's a little bit
more voice something that gets in the
way
a guy because
I'm sad
your head's strong yeah because I'm well
no no you're not you're a sweetheart
you're you're you and her are too
different I'm really headstrong I'm just
kidding but I mean I'm I'm very
independent I have goals for myself I
I think that that comes off as
intimidating to a lot of guys men don't
really care it's okay if a guy tells you
about a shoe collection do you really
care no we don't we don't give a [__]
that's how guys see like our careers and
goals it's cool but like the issue is a
lot of times like women come in all
stressed out and wanting to like talk
about all the stuff when guys just don't
um but I do think the two girls are
different the girl on the right is
obviously a lot more crazy than the girl
talking now what'd you think King what
when women see
um they do this and they do that and
then it might come off as intimidating
to I think you're right is that guys
just don't care women want guys to be
like oh you did this oh you're so good
like we don't care so it's not
intimidating yeah the only the only
thing I've heard about guys dating like
girls with like money or whatever is
it's like a way to mitigate risk for
them because of like the divorce court
like that's the only thing I've ever
heard guys talk about really when it
comes to money is some guys that only
mess with girls with money as a way to
mitigate risk but it doesn't make them
more attracted to you so if you have
money and you don't have feminine
characteristics it's like what's the
point
um why do you think that well that's my
only assumption I might be wrong
I think it's the pipeline more than
anything can I give you guys all a piece
of advice I like him Mark Sartain he's
actually he's really good just down do
whatever with it you want
um I would find a local chapter of the
SPCA and start volunteering there I
would find as many soups what's the sbti
you know the Gins and food pantries that
I couldn't start volunteering there uh I
have found empathetic human beings are
the ones that you probably want to be
with people who show a level of kindness
I throw charity events specifically for
one of the reasons is you generally
people who are narcissists and
Psychopaths can't keep coming to
Charities where they don't get anything
out of it Wounded Warriors anything for
underprivileged children shout out to
the Midnight Mission in Los Angeles
shout out to operations blankets of love
a domestic abuse charity anything like
that the people that are associated with
that I would we used to do that blankets
of love we used to like make do you know
what that is I can't remember what they
did with the blankets I think it was
like homeless things but I remember we
would make like the tie blankets for
those organization I try to find meet
other people I want to group with but I
would also invite a date on that for me
who frequently it used to be my first
date would be it would be somebody that
was interested in we'd go volunteer at a
soup kitchen we go volunteer at a food
pantry because that is such a good idea
reason why is like a lot of the times
you guys are talking about like cruelty
and a lack of empathy I I promise you
that will work better than Tinder when
it comes to personality if you guys
started doing that but I haven't heard
any of you say that because your method
by which you're meeting people tends to
be solely online and I listen I know
Roland I talk about this all the time
Instagram is the number one dating app
in the world and I agree that it's
number one dating app in the world but
it used to not be like that I'm old and
I remember when it wasn't like that
before uh and and so I would recommend
you guys try some IRL stuff uh where
you're actually volunteering and trying
to serve other people and when you find
somebody else in that method especially
with your values as a Christian I think
you're going to be shocked at how
awesome it is and I don't mean just
going to to church I mean finding
someone else who's doing something for
Wounded Warriors or for especially for
animal rescue that is the the catch-all
for everyone any everyone loves Animal
Rescue uh so that's what I would
recommend for all of you guys to if
you're having trouble finding someone
who's compassionate or finding someone
who's trustworthy that's what I would do
if I could just add to that Michael
good chance you'll find a good guy at
those places you might also find someone
who
committed like a misdemeanor and they're
doing community services
I was just saying just just a caveat to
Michael's thing and you might find a Sim
too I mean there's obviously there's
that too right there's that yeah there's
a bit of psychopathy that works for love
there's such thing as dark love for sure
and also interesting trying to think so
I used to volunteer at animal shelter
when I was younger it was mostly women
there I'm not gonna lie look I don't
know if you would find that
um that was interesting though I like
whatever podcast because they have such
an like a very good like a diverse group
of guests
um it's too bad they kind of cut the
exchange off with the super checks I
would have liked to have seen like a
little bit more but I do think that it
is a cope when women say that men are
intimidated by them like no guy is gonna
be intimidated by you like most guys an
average guy can beat you up no guy is
intimidated by you but let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell I'll
talk to you next time